Welcome to Lee's Detective Agency.
We accept all manner of requests
which sometimes include special cases
like detective work.
Reality can be far more surprising than fiction.
But we'll let the police handle the actual investigation.
Detectives like us must stay in the shadows
because the light will rob us of our secrecy.
The same goes for everyone.
Being placed under the spotlight
will make people look different.
The day just ended for someone.
And the day just started for somebody.
In empty streets I walked about
Confessing my boredom out loud.
I wanna keep feeling it
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
I wanna keep feeling it
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
A Minute of Investigation
The boss just got some new art.
This painting looks fake.
Look.
I guess you saw through the disguise.
Please, come in.
Excuse me.
The Lungmen Guard Department has just received a report.
Mr. Meng, a high ranking banker, has gone missing.
Who is she?
You met Mr. Meng at the bar last time.
I'll let Mrs. Meng take over from here.
But I thought this case
is being investigated by the LGD.
He kept a secret lover.
The two of them escaped during the investigation.
How did you learn that he left on his own?
These
are the evidences.
The plane tickets they bought.
His bank records.
And his receipts for buying jewelry.
Why did things end up this way?
So what do you want us to do for you?
He deposited our shared assets
into an encrypted gold card
and placed it at Lee's DA for safekeeping.
The money.
I want it back.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
A case can only be terminated by the original client in person.
I understand.
It's alright, thank you.
I'll just sell the house. That will keep me alive for a while.
WAIT!
I guess we can make an exception.
The half that doesn't belong to me
will go to the LGD.
That will be it for today. Farewell.
WAIT!
Mrs. Meng,
we'll need you to sign a few forms.
It's part of our agency's contract process.
What should we have for dinner tonight?
Why don't you stay for dinner?
We're having chocolate coral fin tonight.
That's so kind of you,
but I really have other matters to attend to.
What is it, young man?
This smells familiar.
What are you doing, boy?
Well, old lady,
you've consumed a chemical
that smells a little like ethanol
except that it isn't.
It's actually a product of loxic kohl.
Your coat is brand new,
and you're allergic to animal fur.
That explains the slight rash under your ears.
Why would someone wearing fur coats all the time be allergic to it?
Despite being married to a renowned banker,
the first digit of your right index finger is callused.
I guess being an assassin
forces you to hold blades all the time.
And most importantly,
you are a man!
SHUT THE DOOR!
I should have killed you all from the start
and not put up with this stupid acting.
Have a taste of my stimpack.
The LGD Special Inspection Unit has found the body of the missing banker Mr. Meng.
The suspect murderer has been apprehended.
The motivation of this crime is money.
We now go live with our correspondent and Officer Hoshiguma at the crime scene.
So that fox
also disguised as this lady.
Aak.
If it weren't for you, that fox would have deceived the old man as well.
Hey! Where's Aak?
I think he went to the mini-mart.
To be continued...
Mrs. Meng requested Lee's D.A
to return the gold card
that Mr. Meng entrusted the Agency for safekeeping.
According to our partnership contract with Mr. Meng,
the gold card can only be returned to Mr. Meng in person.
Should special circumstances apply,
the requestor must first prove that she is Mrs. Meng herself.